hey everybody
oh
man I missed you too oh here it goes oh
here it goes Keenan Thompson reunites
with his childhood co-star Cal Mitchell
on Saturday Night Live With a Little
Help from host Kiki Palmer oh my gosh
Come On Let's talk about
during a sketch for the long-running
comedy show Kiki who announced she's
expecting her first child during the
opening monologue pitches an idea for a
dramatic reimagining of Keenan and Kel
Keenan's 1996 Nickelodeon series with
Cal here we go
what's up I should have asked questions
I thought it was going to be a Jordan
peel Purdue streaming series I would
have said yes to Keenan and kale but now
it's just Kelly safe to say Keenan and
Kelly not so good
uh Kelly
I think that salmon you caught might be
a piranha
here come the bus
Kale's famous catchphrase was oh here it
goes Kiki decided to say uh oh here
comes the bus
of course Keenan and Kel also starred in
the 1997 flick good burger based on
their sketch from Nickelodeon's all that
mind if I sit here yes I do mine ah
thanks and when ET chatted with Keenan
in October he said the long-awaited
sequel could be coming sooner than we
think we're getting really close on Good
Burger too we're gonna figure out when
you know the packet of time will be a
shooter but I'm it's gonna happen it's
closer than it's ever been I don't think
anything's going to derail it as for
KiKi her impression of Kell was pretty
good she even channeled Kel's love of
orange soda who loves orange so
I do I do I do I do
come on Kelly you can't keep taking
orange sodas just put it on my test good
for it okay
[Applause]
thousand dollars worth of orange sodas
Kelly don't yell at me cause
you with your child
Kiki was gunning for an Emmy Award and I
thought that won't work and I was right
and that's when Kel showed up to save
the sketch
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
the last time we saw Keenan and Kel
together was during the 2022 Emmys and
following their reunion on SNL he didn't
thanked Kell for coming out to rock with
them as for Cal he shared a bunch of
behind the scenes snaps writing that it
was an epic night with his bro
oh I missed you oh man I missed you too
[Music]